JPMorgan paid Jamie Dimon I believe 20
million dollars last year help me get up
to a billion dollars so how you get to
be worth 1 point 1 billion dollars is
you start really early making a lot of
money so he was a c-suite got c-suite
guy basically in his 20s you know as he
was basically sandy weill sidekick he
was doing you know top-level jobs for
companies that eventually turned into
citigroup at a very early age so he was
making 20 million you know you know and
at a very early age and when you
compound that over decades that gets to
be a pretty big kitty everybody hasn't
actually been making twenty million
dollars a year over the past 20 years I
mean where where do the big payouts
where on the big payout so what have
been sort of the pivotal cash generating
moments right right and so uh you know a
lot of credit on this valuation we
should go to Pamela roux billionaires
team she has been tracked she's like a
billionaire hunter she's in tracking and
Jamie Dimon for years in her calculation
essentially is that there are two big
buckets one is JPM stock and that's
worth about 480 million
you know dollar so that's roughly half
of his his wealth the other half is
essentially a investment portfolio
that's for the most part seated with
stock from from Citigroup sales from
years ago and the good thing about being
fired from Citigroup which Jamie Dimon
was back in 1998 is that he sold way
before it crashed so he was lucky in a
way all right to make me the case that
he's actually worth the money I know
JPMorgan stock is up 66% since he became
CEO in 2005 obviously the crisis you
know puts a big dent in all the bank
stock performances but 66 percent is not
actually impressive for the past ten
years it's I mean depending on what
sector you're looking at I mean is he
worth it 1.1 billion dollars I would say
yes because you know his valuation is
its own justification you know there are
people who worth a lot more obviously
who've done less I mean this is a guy
who's not sold his stock in JP Morgan
you know or in the stuff where they say
at all so all of you know a huge part of
his net worth is in trying to you know
take this in being a good steward and a
manager of this huge company and
he takes the Bursar's yeah how does
brian moynihan feel about this how did
the other bank CEOs stack up feeling a
little bit small today I don't know I
mean they're for the most part sub
billionaires and because when you think
about it think about the churn in the
CEO level job
these guys don't last very long so to
make a billy to get to a billionaire at
making 20 million dollars a year you
really have to do it for a long time
and Moynihan's been CEO for five years
you know he's had a lot of lesser jobs
before that and he wasn't making his
passion so that's that's why I just to
make you speculate since you do cover
Jamie Dimon I know me and you cover his
character and his career you could have
made a lot more money going away of
savory Dalio you know running his own
fun work what do you think motivates him
to stay at the bank yeah that's a good
point so guys like George sir sorrows
you know Schwartzman worth thirty
billion dollars fifteen billion dollars
and I've come to the conclusion that
Jamie's not primarily motivated by money
he likes being rich you know he's got
the famous quote to an analyst that's
why I'm richer than you you know it was
kind of an infantile thing to say so he
likes being rich but I don't think he's
primarily motivated by money
I think it's primarily motivated by
putting his imprint on a huge vastly
important institution and having that
institution exist after he's long gone